how do I find my passion this is a
critical question for any entrepreneur
because it is the most important rule in
business if you're not passionate about
your company you're not going to be
successful
bottom line none of the other rules
advice information tips will help you if
you're not passionate about your company
the reason is you kind of have to be a
little crazy to be an entrepreneur
because people gonna tell you you're
nuts you're not gonna see any momentum
for a while you're gonna be investing
everything you've got into your company
and constantly worried that it's not
gonna work out because it takes way
longer than you think it's gonna be even
though you know it's gonna be hard I'm
going to take a lot of yourself it's
gonna be way harder and take more of you
than you ever thought possible and
you're gonna think about quitting and
giving up so many times and the other
thing that gets you through is the
passion for what you're doing if you
look at any famous entrepreneur and why
they got started it's because they'd
loved what they did and they would do it
even if they weren't getting paid to do
it a lot of them didn't even think it
would ever become a business they don't
like the business side of it because
they'd love what they did is it's only
that passion that's going to get you
through all the tough times ahead so I
got a question from one of my readers on
my newsletter I'm Misha I mean she wrote
this crazy long email here trying to
find her passion and I get it I mean
this is great this is a great start a
mission for anybody who is thinking
about starting the business this is
important this is where you need to
start if you don't know what your
passion is don't start a business yet
okay now I have an entire zuga guide
that I walk people through how to find
their passion I'm gonna try to condense
that it's quick video for you guys I
mean she writes to say she likes special
education
she likes helping teach kids she likes
psychologies not sure how to bring this
all together
okay I'm Misha here's how you start you
start by making a list of all the things
all the things that you love doing it
okay forget about the business for now
just things that you love doing things
you can get lost in so if it's helping
these kids
it was researching about these kids if
it's finding a solution what
where it is what do you love what can
you get lost in you know for me it was
famous entrepreneur stories I love that
stuff
I could read a biography or a quick
overview of a famous entrepreneur and I
just love it I love it I love seeing it
I get lost and I can spend hours doing
it still now I can watch your videos
that inspire me I still love those
things
and so I had to find a way to make that
into a business what do you love what is
it that you love about kids and teaching
kids or both special needs kids
what is it make a list once you've
identified some of those things and you
can try to match it up to business
opportunity and remember the business
you don't have to be complicated okay
business comes from providing value the
more value give to somebody the more
money you're gonna make you want to make
a lot of money provide a lot of value
you want to make a lot of money quickly
provide a lot of value quickly that's it
this stuff that you love doing how does
it help people the more it helps people
the more money you can be able to charge
for it the more money you're gonna be
able to make that's the intersection
you're looking for something you love
doing with something that helps people
that's how you make a lot of money
that's how you find your winning
business idea okay if you're still not
sure once you get to that point instead
of just starting out putting whatever
job you have right now go work for
somebody who's done it go work for
somebody who is doing what you want to
do or close to what you want to do
there's a couple reasons for it okay
the first is you're gonna learn if
you're taking a job you want to take a
job to learn not just to get paid but to
learn right so if you go work for a
small company say look somebody has 10
employees who's doing something that is
inspiring to you you're gonna learn from
them and and try to take on more
responsibilities and what they've hired
you for any entrepreneur is looking for
star employees they want people to do
more to take on more because every
entrepreneur has tons of work so get
involved get closely the entrepreneur
learn from them it's like you're getting
paid to go to university you're getting
paid to make mistakes somebody else is
paying you to learn about the business
that you want to start and it also lets
you see is this the type of company you
want to start or not because a business
idea can sound great in your head and
then once you get into it you realize oh
this is not for me I don't want to do
this at all so why not get paid to learn
that and it's okay to bounce from one
thing to another thing to another thing
you know it in the eyes of society
they'll see you as a failure like you
can't keep a job down but you're
learning don't care what they think
you're learning you're finding your
passion you're finding something that
you're gonna be able to leverage and
change the world with that's your goal
and once you've done that once you've
found that job and and you're in there
you're hustling and you find out you
know I love this then you can start
thinking how can I turn this into my own
thing and you can start part-time start
on the side I don't want you to start a
job a business and I have to quit in
three months because you ran out of cash
so start part-time build connections
build it up to the point where you can
get to survival with your company and
then expand from there and that may be
the point where you can leave your job
and focus full-time but starting back at
the roots this is a great question every
entrepreneur should ask themselves this
how do I find my passion
am I really passionate about what I'm
doing because if you're not quit now
start something else because I'm I can't
help you if you're just asking how to
make money and you don't love your
business it's not gonna happen you're
gonna have more happiness more
fulfillment make more money have a
greater impact if you do something that
you're passionate about so just remember
that concept you're marrying what you
love to do with what can help people
that's how you're gonna find your
winning business idea again I have the
Zuka guide that walks through that
process step-by-step I tried to do it
quick justice in this video but I
hopefully that helped you I'm excited
for your journey believe for those of
you watching if you like the video
please give it a thumbs up below it
always makes you want to do more for you
and I want to hear what you have to
think how did you find your passion do
you have a question for me that I can
answer leave it in the comments below on
the video response thank you so much and
I'll see you soon